so the misinformation squads victims
will just pile up day by day
pressure campaigns led to our friend
diane bongino being permanently banned
from youtube
over rightly questioning the efficacy of
masks
and oan was just dropped by directv
after it faced calls from far left
advocacy groups and craven talking heads
on cnn again misinformation
so the new sensors seek to purge any
traditional or conservative viewpoints
from the public square even liberals who
question them are ultimately called the
purveyors of misinformation
and they're using government and big
tech to stifle free speech and end all
debate they'll ultimately come for you i
promise you
you know the result though of one group
controlling everything you know
it's called
misinformation joining me now is jd
vance ohio senate candidate
jd i always say this when you allow
one group of activists to shut down
debate
they ultimately come for other people on
the left because
that's all they have is gobbling up
other points of view and suppressing
them your thoughts on this tonight
yeah you're exactly right look at the
end of the day it's not about
misinformation it's not about public
health or anything else it's about
controlling the narrative because the
democrats know that if they have to face
us in an honest debate they're going to
lose so they try to control the
narrative they try to control the facts
and they use their big tech allies to do
exactly that you know one of the things
i i try to remind people though is that
this is enabled by weak republicans that
we send to washington that refuse to
fight back against the tech industry and
all the institutions that control
information in this country so one of
the guys running against me in the
senate is matt dolan a guy who owns the
cleveland indians and when the woke mob
came after the cleveland indians he bent
the knee and changed their name at the
end of the day if you're not willing to
stand up for a team that you own a
legacy institution in the state of ohio
how can you actually stand up against
facebook against google against fouchy
against all of the powerful actors that
are making it hard for conservatives to
actually have a fair stake in this
debate
well china former soviet union russia
today they all use the misinformation
lingo when you really dig in and you
read the translations of of contemporary
you know quote state-sponsored
journalism
it's all about we have to protect the
community from dangerous misinformation
that hurts public harmony all the lingo
that's being used in in schools to shut
down uh concerns about coveted
restrictions
misinformation i mean they are all
working in lockstep jd and they're even
now going after
sub stack the washington post is taking
its quote misinformation crusade against
them saying conspiracy theorists banned
on major social networks connect with
audiences and newsletters and podcasts
newsletter companies substack is making
millions off anti-vaccine content jd
they need to crush all dissent they are
so scared right now
yeah that's exactly right i mean these
people were all hall monitors in middle
school and now they've decided they're
going to complain to the principal
whenever they see anything that
challenges their worldview you know it's
not just covet i think one of the big
issues where misinformation is used to
censor conservatives is the immigration
debate right think about how many of our
own voters laura
think about how many media personalities
have been censored for pointing out the
fact that you've got floods of people
coming across the southern border
completely unchecked of course bringing
fentanyl which is killing our people
bringing sex trafficking they're
censoring that too at the end of the day
these people are trying to control the
debate in this country because they know
they can't win in a fair fight and the
thing i'd ask laura is think about the
history of this when has the has the
group of people trying to censor the
debate censor the narrative ever been
the good guys they never are
well jd republicans have to stand up to
big tech stop falling on the ground for
them which is what they did year after
year after year huge mistake not to you
not to you know take action against them
where appropriate jd good to see you hey
sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else